bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous c'est
sens public votre rendez-vous quotidien
de débat de reportage et d'analyse sur
public c'est la 90 minutes pour donner
du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts et justement vous propose deux
débats d'actu ce soir d'abord la réforme
de l'assurance chômage sous les 9 % de
chômeurs la durée d'indemnisation de la
plupart des allocations sera réduite
d'un quart le ministre du Travail veut
inciter au retour à l'emploi
notre objectif est clair c'est avoir un
système plus incitatif quand les choses
vont bien sur le marché de l'emploi
c'est le cas aujourd'hui d'avoir un
système plus protecteur quand les choses
vont mal et ça levier efficace pour
atteindre le plein emploi cette réforme
est-elle injuste ou indispensable on en
débat dans une minute et puis c'est un
signal d'alarme tiré par les pédiatres
et les infectionnologues le manque
d'amoxicilline risque de déboucher sur
une crise majeure de santé publique dans
les prochains jours comment expliquer la
pénurie de cette antibiotique et de
beaucoup d'autres médicaments comment
restaurer la souveraineté pharmaceutique
de la France et de l'Europe constat et
solutions à découvrir dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord donc le détail des
nouvelles règles de l'assurance chômage
qu'est-ce qui va changer à partir du 1er
février je n'attends du priez
le gouvernement a tranché il ne touchera
pas au montant mais à la durée des
indemnités chômage elles seront plus ou
moins longues selon l'état du marché du
travail si le taux de chômage est
inférieur à 9% pendant 3 trimestres
consécutifs la durée d'indemnisation
sera réduite de 25% avec un plancher
minimum de 6 mois si la réforme
s'appliquait aujourd'hui avec un taux de
chômage à 7,3 % un demandeur d'emploi
normalement indemnisé sur 12 mois verrai
par exemple ses droits réduits à 9 mois
la situation que nous connaissons
actuellement est favorable et nous
considérons que nous reviendrons aux
règles classiques d'indemnisation si le
chômage revenait à niveau supérieur à
9%. ou s'il connaissait une augmentation
de 0,8 points en un trimestre l'objectif
est d'inciter les demandeurs d'emploi à
occuper les postes non pourvu mais les
syndicats n'y croient pas tous sont
opposés à la réforme à commencer par
Laurent Berger le secrétaire général de
la CFDT accuse même le gouvernement de
faire des économies sur le dos ces
nouvelles règles sont très dures pour
les chômeurs injustes et inefficaces
attaquons-nous aux vrais problèmes
attractivité des métiers freins l'emploi
formation et arrêtons de stigmatiser les
demandeurs d'emploi comme le fait le
gouvernement la réforme entre rat en
vigueur le 3 février prochain le
gouvernement table sur 100 à 150 000
retours à l'emploi en 2023 je vous
présente tout de suite les invités de ce
premier débat de Sophie elsive bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes chef économiste du
cabinet d'audit BDO France marque Touati
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
économiste président du cabinet assez
défi auteurs de ce livre reset 2
bienvenue dans le monde d'après le pire
n'est jamais certain nous pouvons encore
l’éviter ces publier chez boukelis
Clément Carbonnier bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi professeur d'économie à
l'Université Paris 8 co directeur de
l'axe politique socio fiscal du liep à
Sciences Po et Mathieu croissanto
éditoris politique
évidemment à mes côtés comme
chaque mercredi et chaque lundi bonsoir
à vous apprenez le tour de table
peut-être pour commencer pour vous
situer tiens par rapport à cette réforme
Anne-Sophie elle peut favoriser le
retour à l'emploi alors elle peut
favoriser le retour à l'emploi à court
terme suite au covid c'est vrai qu'il y
a eu beaucoup de personnes qui ont
changé de secteur et on a créé une forte
demande donc on a vu qu'on avait des
secteurs en tension hébergement
restauration dans la finance dans la
comptabilité donc c'est vrai que pour
résoudre ce problème on va dire à ses
conjoncturels d'embauches dans certains
secteurs spécifiques ça peut être une
solution mais même si on a quand même la
question du de la formation qui est
première parce que même si on incite
quand vous avez on va dire un nombre de
personnes et bien qui n'est pas assez
importante par rapport à la demande il
faut les former ça prend du temps par
contre à moyen long terme sur le plein
d'emploi je pense pas que ce soit une
bonne réforme puisque pour aller à ce
que l'emploi il faudrait baisser de deux
virgule cinq points à 5 % du taux que
l'on a actuellement quand on regarde ces
deux 2,5 points et bien on voit que le
profil des chômeurs ce sont des jeunes
qui n'ont aucune qualification sont
souvent décroché de moins de 25 ans et
l'autre élément ce sont les plus de
50/50 qui cherchent souvent beaucoup un
emploi mais qui malheureusement n'en
trouve pas donc c'est vrai que sur ces
catégories là si on veut vraiment aller
au plein d'emploi il faut avoir à mon
sens des politiques beaucoup plus
efficaces d'accompagnement et pas
seulement l'incitation puisque
l'incitation est là et on y reviendra
évidemment en détail sur la question du
plein emploi et notamment de l'emploi
des seniors marcoitiers est-ce qu'elle
va dans le bon sens pour vous cette
réforme oui moi alors justement on va
bien sûr dans le bon sens c'est pas non
plus la solution miracle mais pas
oublier que nous sommes entre guillemets
nous avons la chance d'être en France de
vivre en France ou si on regarde ce qui
se passe en Europe nous sommes le pays
parmi lesquels il y a la durée d'un
démission la plus longue ainsi on prend
le cas en Allemagne on détaillera ça
tout à l'heure c'est 12 mois en Italie
c'est entre 6 et 12 mois bon ça ça
dépend les des cas donc là on va passer
de 24 à 18 mois au total si on a droit à
tout à tous ces trimestres le seul
problème c'est que on oublie
effectivement l'essentiel c'est que bah
il faut avoir une croissance plus forte
qui génère cette dynamique d'emploi
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a ces
pénuries de main d'oeuvre mais il faut
pas oublier que évidemment quand on
regarde le taux de chômage à 7,3% tel
qu'il affiché c'est très bien sauf que
le vrai taux de chômage c'est à dire si
on regarde ce qu'on appelle le taux de
sous-emploi ça veut dire pas seulement
les chômage de les chômeurs de catégorie
vous savez ce qu'on qu'on compte c'est
catégorie ça veut dire des personnes qui
sont immédiatement disponibles qui ont
fait une recherche active d'emploi et
qui n'ont pas du tout travaillé voilà ça
c'est les 7,3 % et si on regarde
l'ensemble des chômeurs en France on est
plutôt autour des 16% de taux de chômage
donc ce qui veut dire que à côté de ça
il y a 9 patrons sur 10 qui disent
j'arrive pas à embaucher donc voilà la
difficulté c'est que en fait cette
pénurie justement elle vient du fait que
malheureusement on n'a pas une bonne
adéquation entre les formations les
qualifications de la main d'oeuvre et
puis ce que veulent aujourd'hui les
entreprises ça qui est extrêmement
dangereux un exemple derrière moi ou
j'étais au chantier naval de
Saint-Nazaire vous savez donc une belle
réussite française et donc en fait bah
il trouve pas donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait donc pour l'embaucher mais trouve
pas de salarié donc que font-ils ils ont
créé leur propre école en interne pour
justement les qualifications nécessaires
donc c'est quand même assez incroyable
on a l'éducation nationale la plus
coûteuse du monde mais on n'arrive pas à
trouver cette adéquation entre l'offre
et la demande de travail donc c'est
pourquoi ça va dans le bon sens mais le
fait de dire oui ça va créer 150 000
emplois ou 200000 € 250 000 francs
besogne encore une fois je pense ça fait
ça participe de la modernisation du
marché de travail français il faut pas
en attendre non plus des miracles
d'accord Clément Carbonnier je posais la
question en dans mes titres est-ce
qu'elle est injuste ou indispensable
qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à juste injuste mais je crois que les
les les deux les deux personnes qu'on
parlait avant moi on dit qu'il fallait
pas trop en attendre beaucoup sur le
plan de l'emploi et la raison c'est que
c'est une réforme qui joue sur les
incitations c'est à dire c'est une
réforme qui va dire je vais finalement
si vous trouvez pas vite on va vous
pénaliser vous allez avoir moins moins
de temps l'indemnité chormale
18 mois ça suffit pour fonctionner
c'est-à-dire que la question c'est que
ça ne peut fonctionner si le problème
actuel c'est que les gens cherchent pas
or là je crois j'ai l'impression qu'on
est d'accord le problème actuel c'est un
problème de création d'emploi c'est un
problème d'adéquation des compétences
avec les mains c'est pas un problème de
fainéantise des chômeurs c'est pas un
problème d'incitation et donc avoir une
politique qui a pour but juste
l'incitation ben ça va pas passer quand
même les chômeurs ne cherchent pas plus
un emploi quand ils arrivent au bout de
de des mois de nabilisation vous voyez
ce que je veux dire oui mais alors là il
faut faire très très attention sur ça
parce qu'effectivement d'ailleurs le
gouvernement l'année dernière avait
communiqué sur un article qui sur la
France qui regardait très très
précisément ces recherches notamment en
termes de réponse individuelle etc et là
il faut faire attention entre le
quantitatif et le qualitatif
c'est-à-dire que ce qui ce qu'on observe
est-ce qu'observer
cette analyse là c'est que sur la fin
effectivement il y avait un plus grand
taux de réponse de réponse des chômeurs
mais parce que ils se mettaient à
répondre à des choses qui n'avaient rien
à voir avec leur qualifications qui
étaient des CD des cours qui était des
temps partiels etc si on regardait la
part des réponses à des emplois
correspondant à leurs qualification
à temps plein etc ça baisse ça augmente
pas du tout donc en fait c'est là où il
faut faire attention c'est à dire que on
n'est pas incité mais pas mais pas à
trouver le le les emplois qui que
recherchaient ces chômeurs ou qui
correspondent à la formation et on
revient sur ce que disent sur le
question du court terme long terme
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont peut-être
accepter à court terme un CDD ou un
emploi partiel mais ça va pas changer la
situation de l'emploi à long terme c'est
à dire que s'ils acceptent un CDD d'un
mois un mois plus tard il se rend à
nouveau au chômage Matthieu lit
intervenir je trouve que c'est une
réforme de gens qui n'ont jamais connu
le chômage c'est des gens qui expliquent
qui n'ont pas connu ce que c'est que la
désocialisation du chômage parce que
c'est que la perte d'estime de soi du
chômage parce que c'est que le stress la
difficulté et donc qui estime que tous
les chômeurs sont des chômeurs stratèges
qui calculent exactement leur indemnité
et qui attendent pour rechercher du
boulot il y en a sans doute des chômeurs
stratèges il y en a peut-être plus
depuis le covid parce que les gens ont
appris à se dire bah voilà je vais
m'offrir une période comme ça
le chômage c'est quelque chose qui
marque c'est quelque chose qui frappe
c'est quelque chose qui fait souffrir
donc imaginez que tout le monde est un
chômeur stratège à mon avis c'est une
absurdité il y a toute une partie des
chômeurs qui de toute façon indemnité ou
pas indemnité ne sont exclues de ce
monde du travail parce qu'ils n'ont pas
les qualifications requises parce que
les entreprises veulent pas les
débaucher les embaucher maintenant et
qui eux vont tomber dans ce qu'on
appelle les trappes à pauvreté et puis
le système de du RSA voilà et qui eux
sont exclus de ça il y a tous les
anciens tous les seniors vous l'avez dit
qu'il cherche du boulot et que eux dont
les entreprises ne veulent pas parce que
on va le payer trop cher parce qu'il est
pas assez formé parce qu'il est pas
assez moderne donc pour un senior c'est
36 mois aujourd'hui c'est neuf mois de
perdu avec avec donc il y a quand même
toute une grande masse des chômeurs qui
aimerait bien bosser et qui voilà et qui
qui constigatise à mon avis en imaginant
qui serait cool douce sur leur canapé à
calculer exactement bah faut que je
mette le 13 parce que on indemnité 5 le
18 c'est pas comme ça la vintage il y a
une autre façon de le dire c'est
chômeurs fainé en quoi est-ce que est-ce
que derrière barkoti cette réforme il y
a cette espèce de petite musique qu'on
entend régulièrement à propos des des
demandeurs c'est d'accord l'essentiel
des chômeurs sont pas effectivement
chômeurs faignants ou autres mais ce qui
est clair par contre c'est que plus on
reste longtemps au chômage plus on perd
de son employabilité c'est-à-dire on est
plus au contact du marché du travail et
ça c'est extrêmement dangereux et c'est
là où effectivement on se dit d'ailleurs
moi c'est le conseil que je donne ça met
même arrivé de d'être au chômage parfois
et ou de le conseil qu'on peut donner
aujourd'hui aux personnes qui tombent
malheureusement au chômage c'est
justement de il y a des aides vous savez
qui vous permettent justement de
réceptionner la somme totale d'un seul
coup en deux fois et après par contre au
bout effectivement de 18 mois ou de 14
mois on a plus rien et ça c'est vrai que
ça ça vous incite à ne pas trop attendre
et à rester dans le marché du travail
donc vous dites il y a un cercle vicieux
de de d'une durée d'indemnisation
que l'on connaît bien et donc c'est vrai
qu'après quand on est plus au contact
alors bien entendu c'est humain
également de se dire attends ça porte
bien son nom c'est une assurance chômage
dire que quand on cotise effectivement
tous les mois sur ces salaires pour
l'assurance chômage ça veut dire que
comme toute assurance une fois que vous
êtes au chômage vous avez le droit de
toucher ces sommes là par contre ce qui
est clair c'est encore une fois sinon on
peut se dire bon bah j'ai un petit peu
le temps d'attendre là non justement si
on sait que au bout de 18 mois et bien
la roue tourne et là mais est-ce que
c'est pas le pardon de 20 € je reviens à
vous Clément Carbonnier est-ce que c'est
pas presque la philosophie du système
qui change là on se dit c'est presque un
outil de politique conjoncturel c'est
plus exactement la même chose quoi oui
alors après la la philosophie générale
de l'assurance chômage à évolué depuis
longtemps il y a eu une forme
d'étatisation qui sert au départ c'était
c'était même pas la sécurité sociale
c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui était géré par le
monde du travail les employeurs les
employés et qui étaient une protection
sociale au fur et à mesure et là on voit
bien les débats qu'on a c'est pas des
débats de protection sociale on se pose
pas la question comment on protège des
salaires on se dit comment on gère de la
main d'oeuvre comment en période de
pénurie de main d'oeuvre on l'oriente
etc donc on est effectivement dans une
politique qui a le le l'État a repris en
main euh au fur et à mesure hein c'est
pas c'est pas nouveau et utilise cette
reprise en main pour effectivement
détourner d'un d'un but qui a un but de
protection et on se passe pas beaucoup
la question de la situation
effectivement des chemins parce que ça
peut avoir des conséquences assez assez
importantes sur les chômeurs et sur les
personnes en emploi d'ailleurs en termes
de en termes d'inégalité et en termes de
niveau de vie on se pose juste la
question de comment gérer des masses de
main d'oeuvre de secteurs vers d'autres
sans réfléchir vraiment forcément
aux compétences et nécessaire pour faire
pour faire
ce système il existe au Canada aux
États-Unis mais bon les les pays et les
systèmes de protection sont évidemment
pas comparables voilà c'est ça aussi le
problème qu'il faut voir dans ce type de
réforme à mon sens ça augmente les
inégalités et vous l'avez dit la
stigmatisation parce que on parle de
quel type de chômeur les chômeurs donc
disait très fort c'est des gens qui sont
assez qualifiés qui sont intégrés contre
255 ans et donc dès que vous reprises
économique bah oui il y a une très forte
demande vous changez vous changez pour
avoir un meilleur salaire etc donc vous
êtes un petit peu les gagnants de la
situation économique et donc en effet en
quelques mois vous allez plein d'offres
etc mais si on veut vraiment aller au
plein d'emploi c'est pas cette catégorie
là qui faut toucher c'est pas là où il
faut orienter la politique publique sans
vraiment on l'a dit les gens qui sont
durablement hors emploi et quand
vraiment un problème de qualification et
aux États-Unis au Canada c'est vrai que
c'est pas du tout comparable parce que
c'est des systèmes beaucoup plus
flexibles où il y a beaucoup plus
d'indépendants beaucoup plus de gens qui
sont en CDD il y a beaucoup moins de CDI
et donc vous avez un système du travail
que beaucoup plus flexible où vous avez
une reprise mais là vous allez avoir une
très forte augmentation de création
d'emploi vous allez la récession laver
en 2020 aux États-Unis où les gens avec
le covid se faisaient licencier en ligne
et bien en effet vous avez jusqu'à 15%
de taux de chômage donc ce n'est pas du
tout la même structure à son marché du
travail donc c'est vrai que vouloir
l'appliquer en France ça peut être bon
en effet sur la catégorie on va dire de
j'irai pas de faux chômeurs mais de
personnes en fait qu'utilisent la
conjoncture économique pour améliorer je
préfère le conditions de travail et
c'est bien mais à mon sens ça ne règle
pas le problème de de l'accès aux pleine
emploi sur les personnes qui sont
durablement en dehors du système
j'entends ça mais je reprends l'argument
que vous nous donniez dans votre
première intervention peut-être qu'à
court terme c'est c'est ce dont on a
besoin parce que encore une fois je
reviens à cette incapacité beaucoup de
d'employeurs aujourd'hui à trouver de la
madame juste pour réagir vous avez 55
ans vous avez fait tout votre carrière
dans une filière vous avez une
qualification spécifique et vous envoyer
des CV et des CV vous êtes tout à fait
d'accord pour avoir les formations etc
mais on ne vous emploie pas à cause de
votre âge vous pouvez avoir toutes les
incitations du monde c'est un fait et ça
malheureusement c'est vraiment ces
catégories qui vont être très touchées
donc là on le disait en effet c'est pas
un problème d'incitation je reviens au
court terme quand même le si on essaye
de trouver alors je sais pas si cette
solution est pas la bonne mais de
trouver des solutions là pour
il y a quand même ce paradoxe quoi
c'est-à-dire encore une fois neuf
patrons sur 10 qui disent on trouve pas
de de personnel et puis les chiffres que
vous donniez tout à l'heure il y a les
7,3% et puis il à lourd ce qu'on appelle
le halo du chômage c'est ceux qui
veulent trouver un emploi mais qui n'y
arrivent pas par contre vous avez le
sous-emploi ou il y a des personnes qui
sont complètement désespérés de trouver
un emploi donc là où on monte
effectivement à 16% taux de chômage là
c'est c'est ça le vrai jeu la réalité du
chômage en France à court terme on fait
quoi alors là non il y a 2 ans il faut
savoir que ce que ce qui est pratique
aujourd'hui en France il a été fait ça a
été fait dans toute l'Europe et ça
fonctionnait dans certains pays
notamment en Allemagne on a
effectivement le plein emploi même si la
structure n'est pas pareil bien entendu
mais c'est vrai que encore une fois on
n'est pas mal noté en France il y a pas
c'est que on a l'impression que là c'est
très dur et cetera c'est une catastrophe
faut bien prendre conscience qu'en
France nous avons la chance de vivre en
France où on a un poids des dépenses
sociales de 32% du PIB donc la moyenne
de l'OCDE c'est 20% on est numéro 1 dans
le monde donc on a un système protecteur
il peut être un tout petit peu moins
c'est un protection je sais pas c'est
encore une fois c'est pas les États-Unis
et c'est pas c'est pas la loi de la
jungle c'est pas l'ultra libéralisme
parce que des fois on a on passe d'un
extrême à l'autre après il y a cet enjeu
que vous vous évoquez c'est vrai que moi
ce qui m'a beaucoup vous inquiéter
pendant ces périodes de coronavirus
c'est presque philosophique c'est qu'on
a perdu le sens de la valeur travail
finalement c'est à dire que ou
globalement on avait le sentiment voilà
on l'a bien vu alors que même aux
États-Unis
nation ça veut dire la grande démission
même aux États-Unis vous voyez
finalement personne ne sont dit bon
finalement on a des aides finalement on
va on va se spéculer sur les crypto
monnaie etc et autres finalement à quoi
bon donc là on remet l'église au centre
du village c'est-à-dire que c'est ça
effectivement
ce côté-là de la table donc vous dites
on est en train de perdre la on oublie
une chose simple comment on crée de la
richesse avec le travail bon c'est ça le
plus important donc moi je trouve que
c'est important aujourd'hui et c'est
vrai que le problème c'est qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un saut c'est-à-dire entre
la période où on est au chômage et la
période où on travaille ou qu'il y a un
saut de revenus et effectivement non
alors vu que ça beaucoup plus élevé il y
a des enquêtes de l'Insee qui ont été
menées justement on dit que
malheureusement bah tu en parlais il y a
des poches à précarité qui se créent ou
finalement la station est pas énorme
donc
plus besoin de la parole juste après là
je pense qu'il y a de deux choses après
la valeur travail etc on est plus sur le
le moral et les valeurs pas forcément
sur les chiffres quand vous regardez
véritablement les chiffres aux
États-Unis vous avez un salarié sur
quatre qui a changé de secteur parce que
c'était souvent des des personnes qui
avaient deux trois emplois et qui
n'arrivaient pas à vivre juste de leur
travail et donc ils ont profité en effet
des plans de relance Biden et autres
pour avoir de la formation comment en
France pour justement augmenter le
marché du travail
mais moi aussi
je veux finir mon propos comme vous
l'avez fait vous regardez donc il y a eu
un changement en effet le secteur qui
s'est fait par une augmentation de
qualification donc ça veut dire une
augmentation de valeur ajoutée pour
justement mieux payer et c'est
d'ailleurs le présent américain qui l'a
dit ben écoutez s'il y a autant de
changements de secteurs c'est parce
qu'ils étaient pas assez payés donc
c'est bien qu'il soit mieux bon c'est
quand même pas un communiste et autres
donc c'était vraiment l'occasion en fait
d'utiliser cette période pour avoir une
adéquation entre le capital humain vous
avez beaucoup de gens qui étaient sous
employés ou qui étaient moins payés et
une réelle location va dire de marcher
classique vous en appelez souvent à vos
vœux c'était juste l'offre et la demande
et donc des augmentations de salaire
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec la part de
la paire de la valse juste après les
gens veulent plus travailler ça n'a
absolument rien à voir
non plus je lui laisse un arrivera ça
crée un autre point alors je suis assez
d'accord mais je vais partir sur un
autre point marteau tu as dit quelque
chose à soulever un point qui est
important qui est il faut pas forcément
regarder que le taux de chômage il faut
regarder en fait les gens en emploi et
d'ailleurs si on prend l'exemple
américain visiblement ils ont pas tant
que ça la valeur travail parce que le
taux d'emploi alors si on met de côté
les plus de 55 ans parce que les plus de
55 ans il y a il y a un problème
particulier en France qui peut être
aussi lié en partie aux conditions de
travail qui a un autre problème si on
regarde les 25 55 ans le taux d'emploi
et
plus faible aux États-Unis qu'en France
donc derrière il y a pas de chômage
certes mais il y a beaucoup d'inactifs
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas
en emploi et et pareil vous avez dit ça
a marché en Allemagne mais pas si bien
que ça effectivement il y a des gens
d'emploi alors là le taux d'emploi
lui-même il est bon en Allemagne mais en
fait on a créé que des demi emplois des
Cards d'emploi c'est des mini-jobs si
vous regardez le pareil sur les 25 54
ans le taux la part de la population en
emploi à plein temps en Allemagne est
encore inférieur bien inférieur à ce
qu'elle est en France et c'est pas parce
que la France a des performances
extraordinaires de ce côté là c'est
parce que l'Allemagne fait moins bien et
l'Allemagne fait moins bien parce que
elle a elle fait des emplois de très
loin on peut dire que c'est
philosophique est-ce qu'il faut mieux
être au chômage ou avoir un mini job
alors en terme de sociabilité
on revient sur un autre point
effectivement qui est la question de de
la de la perte en fait de la perte de
compétences pendant la question du
chômage de longue durée fait
effectivement un vrai problème et c'est
là encore une fois où est-ce qu'on
s'intéresse du de du côté de la
protection de la protection sociale des
travailleurs ou est-ce que on fait juste
de la gestion de main d'oeuvre parce que
si les gens si on s'est mis d'accord au
débat pour dire si il trouve pas
d'emploi c'est pas parce qu'ils
cherchent pas ceux qui ont les
compétences il trouve tout de suite et
en fait ceux qui restent c'est pas qui
cherchent pas assez bah c'est pas en les
incitant plus qu'ils vont trouver c'est
juste ils vont sortir un plan massif de
formation c'est et donc non il y a pas
il y a il y a pas que ça il y a il faut
voir aussi il y a la question dire bah
oui mais ils vont prendre un CD des
cours qui est pas dans leur domaine hein
l'horticulteur il va prendre un CDD à
mi-temps dans la restauration ok la
question c'est est-ce que ça
effectivement ça lui permet de garder
ses compétences la réponse est non quand
on prend des petits emplois qu'on cumule
on ne on détériore ses compétences de la
même manière que quand on est au chômage
de longue durée donc c'est aller c'est
créer des des possibilités pour aller
vers des vrais emplois pour conserver
les compétences allez j'ouvre un
chapitre un peu plus politique dans ce
dans ce débat avec vous Mathieu parce
qu'on on la trouve cette dimension
politique dans l'analyse de la
trajectoire du ministre Olivier du socle
oui parce que c'est Olivier c'est un peu
celui que personne n'a vu venir c'est un
politique discret il donne pas beaucoup
dans la punchline quand il parle on
dirait parfois qu'il va s'excuse il
s'excuse ou presque qui va pleurer il
est très très bien de nouveau chez mais
depuis plusieurs mois c'est le ministre
qui monte pourquoi dans la macronyme
parce qu'il fait le job au niveau du
subt n'importe pas toujours été
macroniste il faut appeler qu'en 2017 il
avait même des faits un candidat de la
République en marche au législative ce
qui devrait relever à l'époque de
l'exploit pour un socialiste parce
qu'Olivier du socle oui oui messieurs
dames étaient bien socialiste il a
commencé son parcours à gauche bien à
gauche même puisqu'il était dans le
courant de Benoît Hamon alors au niveau
du socle il a l'air des choix il a
grimpé quatre à quatre tous les échelons
de l'appareil socialiste il devient coup
sur coup le benjamin de l'Assemblée
nationale en 2007 puis le maire
d'Annonay il est repéré par Martine
Aubry dont il deviendra le porte-parole
pendant la primaire socialiste de 2011
donc c'était vraiment quelqu'un qui
était ancré dans dans qui a commencé son
parcours politique et sa formation
intellectuelle dans cette famille de
pensée là bon après il a un recentrage 5
ans plus tard dans la première
socialiste toujours mais en soutenant
Manuel Valls mais ses débuts avec la
macronie seront sans concession puisque
à l'automne 2017 Olivier du soft qui a
voté contre la confiance Édouard
Philippe votre acompte les ordonnances
de la loi travail et votre a contre le
budget aussi de l'année et donc ça
bascule en décembre 2017 puisqu'il
rentre au gouvernement oui c'est la
surprise ou plutôt une prise tout court
pour Emmanuel Macron qui le nomme
secrétaire d'État auprès du ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics et là on
mesure là toute la bilité dans certains
la part de machiavélisme diront d'autres
du président qui confiera 5 ans plus
tard à cet homme venu de la gauche une
réforme imaginée par la droite pour
réformer l'assurance chômage car depuis
pourquoi il lui confie pas parce que
Olivier dussobe qu'il a fait son trou il
a pris du galon il a été ministre de
budget sous Jean Castex il est devenu
ministre du Travail sous Elisabeth borne
les leaders syndicaux qui s'attendaient
à trouver un homme de gauche découvre un
homme plutôt dur en affaires ces anciens
amis se pincent on le voyant faire à
Miami avec Gérald Darmanin sur prochaine
loi immigration alors les deux hommes
qui viennent tous les deux en milieu
populaire qui n'ont tous les deux pas
fait Léna font partie de ces rares
profils pures politiques dans la
macronie où il y a beaucoup de techno
ils sont montés en grade par la force de
l'ambition sinon par leur convictions
alors on peut se demander que reste-t-il
aujourd'hui d'Olivier du subt à gauche
qui reste-t-il plutôt de gauche chez
Olivier du sol une histoire à coup sûr
un engagement aussi aujourd'hui à tenter
de faire vivre une microscopique aile
gauche dans la macronie avec son petit
parti territoire de progrès mais en
politique on dit souvent qu'il y a pas
d'amour il n'y a que des preuves d'amour
et ces derniers temps les preuves
d'amour de gauche au lieu du socle elles
sont de plus en plus rares chez une
ministre de gaufres préférés de la
droite confié à cet homme menu de la
gauche une réforme imaginée par la
droite pour l'assurance chômage
marketier est-ce que c'est une réforme
d'inspiration libérale mais je comprends
mieux pourquoi il est pas tellement
motivé quand il annonce effectivement
cette réforme maintenant je comprenais
pas pourquoi mélanger Mathieu nous a
tout expliqué bravo comme quoi la
politique c'est incroyable c'est
vraiment un milieu spécial enfin bref on
peut changer la vie aussi oui on peut
jouer de la vie mais oui j'ai
l'impression qu'il a pas comment il est
il a pas complètement changé la vie non
moi je peux encore une fois je pense
c'est pas le problème c'est qu'on aime
on aime mettre des étiquettes en France
quand je tiens ce discours oh mais non
mais c'est un méchant libéral c'est le
méchant etc bon moi pas du tout moi je
suis moi je suis je suis pour la liberté
donc c'est moins de coté libéral et moi
je suis keynésien moi je viens de cité
HLM d'Orly parce que je veux dire donc
j'ai réussi à m'en sortir parce que moi
je sais justement ce que c'est le
chômage c'est que c'est les soins de
mois difficiles est-ce que je veux dire
donc mais la plupart des gens justement
ne sont pas passés par là
malheureusement donc ils ont ils ont pas
vécu donc ils suivent des modèles bête
et méchants ou il suivent des théories
mais ils sont pas dans la réalité et
c'est ça aujourd'hui qui est qui est
particulièrement difficile je pense moi
il faut pas être ni libéral ni keynésien
ni autre il faut être pragmatique faut
faire preuve de bon sens et donc
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on a encore
une fois en terme d'employabilité c'est
cette durée d'admission qui est à mon
avis trop longue et moi je l'avais écrit
déjà dans un lit il y a très longtemps
que ça plaît guérir la France c'était
rapide choc ou justement j'ai appelé à
cette réduction qui t'a peut-être même
donné la même somme et on donne la même
somme d'indemnisation mais sur une
période plus courte pour inciter
justement à retrouver davantage alors
bien entendu après on a un problème de
qualification ça qui est qui est clair
et net donc là bon je pense qu'on se
rejoint tous de ce point de vue là c'est
qu'on a aujourd'hui ce problème on n'a
pas anticipé quand on parle de rien
industrialiser le pays par exemple c'est
la tarte à la crème on est tous d'accord
il faut c'est ce qu'il faut faire on va
parler dans notre seconde partie sur
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais comment
fait-on on n'a pas on n'a pas les
formations
c'était un choix politique
des années 80-90 on voulait
rappelez-vous une économie française
sans usine mais tout euh gérer tous les
économistes de l'époque jamais mais
c'est une super idée vous voyez donc
tout le problème est là c'est qu'il faut
avoir une vision du monde que nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui et ça va prendre
du temps avant avant de pouvoir avoir
les emplois industriels qu'on veut en
France je peux aller l'exemple d'une
entreprise tout à l'heure effectivement
ça va prendre du temps mais la clé elle
est là elle est effectivement dans la
formation ce qu'on appelle la
destruction créatrice pour prendre un
terme de schumbédé à se dire on va
détruire des emplois les anciens
secteurs d'activité mais on va en créer
beaucoup plus dans les nouveaux mais
pour faire ça il faut que la main
d'oeuvre puisse passer d'un secteur la
période de transition elle est
douloureuse voilà c'est exactement le
danger qui risque de nous arriver là en
ce moment Anne-Sophie alors
ça va être toujours un petit peu le bon
sens avec des des guillemets parce qu'on
économie est une science sociale et donc
ce n'est pas une science dure donc une
science sociale c'est des écoles de
pensée avec en effet des utilisations de
données et quand vous mettez en place
une politique publique ça a des
évaluations et ça a des conséquences qui
peuvent être différentes aujourd'hui on
a cette problématique sur le le chômage
vous regardez en effet tous les rapports
qui ont été faits dans ils disent où il
y aura des emplois en tension depuis 20
ans et où il faut former on en a parlé
du codage on a parlé de l'ingénierie
donc tout ça on le sait donc c'est pas
une histoire de bon c'est une histoire
tous ces rapports c'est des rapports il
y a 20 ans on se souvient de Jérémy
rifki la troisième révolution
industrielle etc donc on savait et on
sait dans les données où va être créé la
valeur ajoutée et où il faut former pour
garder encore cette valeur ajoutée donc
attention au bon sens il y a quand même
des politiques économiques il y a quand
même des théories et des courants et en
effet quand vous mettez en place tel ou
telle politique et bien vous avez aussi
les conséquences qui vont et là c'est
vrai que pour cette petite là on en
parle à cours moyen terme il y a
vraiment un problème de capital humain
et de risque de le perdre on en a parlé
un petit peu de risques de de de prendre
des emplois qui sont pas forcément en
adéquation donc à court terme c'est pas
grave parce que là on a vraiment un choc
de demande et donc les entreprises ont
beaucoup de besoins mais à moyen long
terme attention encore une fois de ne
pas détruire ce capital humain quand on
a des industrialisés qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé juste pour c'est que justement on
a créé on a détruit l'emploi industriel
donc un emploi industriel c'est trois
emplois dans les services qui ont été
détruits et ces personnes qui ont subi
la désindustrialisation n'ont pas eu la
formation donc on leur a dit voilà vous
avez 50 ans vous avez été toute votre
vie dans l'industrie on ne vous donne
pas une nouvelle formation pour
aujourd'hui faire un nouvel emploi donc
ça ce sont des choix de politique c'est
pas du bon sens c'est des choix qui sont
faits exactement Clément carbonis ça
c'est censé démarrer le premier février
cette réforme est-ce que vous pensez que
pendant
les premiers mois la première année il
peut y avoir quand même une efficacité
même si c'est pour
ramener à inciter des gens à prendre des
emplois qui sont pas forcément
efficacités
dans les chiffres si effectivement on
radis des gens parce que ils auront
effectivement ils sont dans une
compétence ils ont pris le temps
d'essayer de chercher un emploi dans
dans le dans leur filière là où ils sont
compétents ils ont pris un petit boulot
à côté et que dans le petit boulot à
côté avec un très mauvais salaire et des
mauvaises conditions on leur propose un
CDI et que du coup ils sont radiés du
chômage alors effectivement on va avoir
les chiffres maintenant on n'aura pas de
chute de l'emploi qui augmente pour
revenir sur la question que vous posiez
sur la finalement la philosophie
générale de cette réforme si le principe
infinait ça va pas changer grand chose
sur sur la quantité d'emploi réel des
vrais emplois
ça sera pas sans conséquence puisque
derrière il va y avoir effectivement une
multiplication de ces petits boulots qui
seront pas des vrais emplois etc et ça
va faire une pression aussi sur les
salariés en poste et ça c'est important
c'est-à-dire que ça va avoir un impact
sur les négociations salariales dans les
entreprises et a priori on peut
s'attendre à ce que ce soit des baisses
de salaire et là on rejoint des
politiques depuis bien plus longtemps en
France on a vu que ces derniers temps
finalement on avait l'impression que le
point le plus important en politique
économique c'était surtout de faire en
sorte que les salaires n'augmentent pas
la fameuse boucle inflation salaire
c'est vraiment le plus grand danger et
ça rejoint on a vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure des lois travail qui
décentralisent la négociation c'est quoi
appartement on met la négociation au
niveau des entreprises plus qu'au niveau
des branches en fait on diminue le
pouvoir des salariés parce qu'on joue
sur la compétition entre les entreprises
pour baisser les salaires on a etc etc
et si on remonte avant alors c'était pas
baisser les salaires c'était baissé le
coût du travail avec un certain nombre
de politiques donc en fait ça rejoint
des politiques depuis 20 ou 30 ans qui
ont comme objectif principal de faire
baisser le coût du travail au départ et
aujourd'hui directement les salaires il
a une bonne façon de regarder la
coloration de cette réforme c'est que
globalement on a on peut ne pas dire
gauche ou droite mais c'est une réforme
qui est d'inspiration patronale c'est un
refrain qu'on entend dans le patron d'un
français quand Denis Kessler Medef avec
son contrat d'aide au retour à l'emploi
il y a ça devait être il y a 20 ans 25
ans c'était déjà la même idée donc ça ne
s'est pas une réforme d'inspiration
syndicale les syndicats ont jamais été
pour une réforme paille après qui crie
les emplois mais après la question des
salaires elle est importante parce que
c'est vrai qu'on dit pénurie comment ça
se fait qu'il y a autant de chômeurs
alors que il y a des postes qui ne sont
pas pourvu mais on est quand même dans
un changement de paradigme comme par
hasard au moment pile ou le rapport de
force est en train de se rééquilibrer
entre l'employeur et le salarié parce la
pyramide des âges vieillit parce que les
gens veulent du sens aussi dans leur
boulot parce que voilà on a envie de
perspective on a envie d'évolution un
peu différente que la façon dont ça se
déroulait jusqu'à présent mais qu'est-ce
qu'on choisit de faire on choisit de
beauté les fesses des chômeurs plutôt
que d'inciter les employeurs à changer
leur façon de faire c'est un choix c'est
une coloration c'est c'est pas parce que
elle est d'inspiration patronale qu'elle
est forcément mauvaise cette planète
donc encore une fois n'oublions pas que
ce cri les emplois c'est comme les
effectivement les les entreprises malgré
tout qu'on le veuille ou non et que d'un
autre côté c'est pas les salaires qui
baissent c'est le coup du truc du
travail qu'on fait donc un moyen
d'augmenter effectivement les salaires
net si on baisse les charges qui pèse
sur les salaires donc là ça serait
également une politique un choix
politique par contre je voudrais voir
répondre à votre question sur
l'évolution du chômage à venir
malheureusement chômage va augmenter bah
oui parce que on a des prévisions
on a fait plusieurs débats ensemble et
quand on suit les prévisions du FMI ou
d'autres de l'OCDE bref vivement
généralement il se trompent bien entendu
le vrai enjeu il est clair c'est
aujourd'hui on a une situation où nous
sommes une dans une récession qui est en
train d'arriver avec une inflation qui
est très aimée ce qu'on appelle une
stackflation non pas dans les termes peu
importe et donc si il y a pas d'activité
économique quand vous allez créer des
emplois ce que le but il est là c'est
pas tellement parce que je suis d'accord
avec vous hein vous voyez le Talk
chômage il va baisser artificiellement
si effectivement on fait des radiations
ou qu'on crée des faux-emploi le chômage
officiel de catégorie va baisser et le
taux de sous-entendais à un mode de
réponse après je compare dans un
comparatif européen donc le temps suivi
par contre pour terminer si
effectivement on a une récession
économique qui est en train de d'arriver
en France quand vous allez créer des
ordres quelle que soit les donc grosso
modo quel que soit les réformes
le FMI tous ces modèles qui tout le
monde a faux mais déjà rien qu'en
regardez la kit croissance normalement
on est à 0,4 donc en tout cas il y a un
risque ça veut dire ça veut dire par
rapport à la croissance N-1 donc on est
juste fini je fini
déjà calculé c'est il faut regarder les
statistiques donc déjà quand on regarde
pour la France on traite pas dans un
risque de récession par contre on est
pour en Allemagne et on est pour en
effet la zone euro et ce qui se passe
pour les prévisions en effet d'inflation
c'est que justement comme on va avoir
moins d'activités ce que vous dites et
contradictoires que vous avez moins
d'activités bien forcément vous avez
tout de suite un impact sur
l'auto-inflation qui va baisser avec en
plus une politique de tout genre la page
je reprends la main merci maxwati je
reprends la non non je vous laisse pas
je vous laisse pas entrer dans cette
Bada parce que et je ressens pardon je
suis un peu basique mais je vais
vraiment recentrer sur j'ai bien compris
j'ai bien compris j'ai bien compris
j'arriverai pas à vous mettre d'accord
et on va s'y perdre un peu donc je vais
vous proposer une autre réaction vous
nous parliez de d'Olivier du soft
finalement c'est un parcours un peu
similaire de d'un autre homme politique
de gauche ancien ministre du Travail
c'est François hepsamen le maire de
Dijon il était ce matin sur notre
antenne invité Dorian Mancini voilà ce
qui dit de de cette réforme écoutez
c'est une baisse incontestablement je
vais pas dire le contraire des
indemnisations avant pour un jour
travailler en avait un jour qui pouvait
être ainsi indemnisé aujourd'hui on va
être à
75%, ça reste quand même il faut le dire
le degré d'indemnisation plus élevé
d'Europe donc il faut relativiser
toujours ce genre de choses bon moi je
préférerais que ça se passe tout ça en
accord avec les organisations syndicales
dans le cadre d'un dialogue social mais
il est difficile parce que aujourd'hui
le dialogue social il est un peu
interrompu on va dire et je compte sur
le musée du socle pour le remettre
oui je la comprends je la comprends pour
les raisons que comme les Français je
préfère le travail à l'indemnisation
voilà François bref ça va être qui lui
aussi
a avancer dans son chemin vers la
macronie on est clair ça reste quand
même le degré d'indemnisation le plus
élevé d'Europe voilà ce que nous affirme
l'ancien ministre du Travail on va
vérifier tout ça tout de suite avec
Jérémy ineman bonsoir Jérémy bienvenue
comparatif avec
avec nos voisins européens oui alors
pour tenter de répondre et d'éclaircir
la situation on peut déjà commencer par
regarder et bien la durée minimale de
travail nécessaire pour toucher les
allocations chômage chez nos voisins
européens en France par exemple il faut
avoir travaillé au moins 6 mois sur les
24 derniers mois pour percevoir ces
allocations et bien ces deux fois plus
de temps qu'en Italie ou la durée
minimale est de 3 mois mais c'est aussi
deux fois moins de temps que dans
beaucoup d'États européens comme
l'Allemagne et l'Espagne ou la durée
minimale et de 12 mois pour percevoir
les allocations ensuite on peut
s'attarder et bien sur ce qui est
important finalement dans cette réforme
c'est la durée d'indemnisation dans les
différents pays d'Europe calculer elle
en fonction de la durée du travail en
France on peut bénéficier d'allocations
chômage entre 6 mois et 24 mois maximum
voire plus au-delà de 55 ans une durée
maximale 24 mois similaire en Italie en
Espagne et aux Pays-Bas et une durée qui
est moins avantageuse en Allemagne 12
mois maximum seulement ou au Portugal 18
mois mais une durée bien plus
avantageuse vous allez le voir dans un
pays la Belgique ou la durée maximale de
prise en charge peut atteindre 48 mois
c'est à dire 4 ans à noter que dans
certains pays les durées d'indemnisation
elles sont forfaitaires six mois par
exemple au Royaume-Uni et 24 mois au
Danemark peu importe finalement la
période travaillée et alors que dire du
montant de ces indemnisations et bien
c'est un montant calculer par rapport au
salaire de l'emploi perdu évidemment et
c'est un montant surtout qui est
plafonné dans la plupart des pays
européens alors en France le plafond est
assez généreux c'est plus de 7000 euros
mais ce qui est important c'est que chez
nous l'allocation chômage assure
seulement 57% du salaire journalier de
référence c'est l'un des taux les plus
faibles en Europe c'est bien moins par
exemple qu'en Allemagne le taux est
compris entre 60 et 67% du salaire ou
qu'en Espagne c'est 70% du salaire mais
dans ce pays le montant indemnisation et
lui dégressif merci beaucoup Jérémy
Anne-Sophie alsif finalement quand
François epsamé nous dit la France reste
face à reste quand même le degré
d'animation le plus élevé d'Europe on
n'y est pas tout à fait quoi voilà ça
dépend on l'a dit voilà tout à fait
c'est complexe et puis c'est vrai que
c'est un raisonnement économique un peu
bizarre parce que le but c'est de
regarder quel est le profil de vos
chômeurs dans votre pays ce sont des
marchés de l'emploi qui sont pas
comparables on le sait l'Allemagne a
fait d'autres choix politiques justement
de modération salariale pendant des
années de réindustrialisation nous on a
fait le choix justement des services
donc voilà c'est pas du tout des marchés
du travail comparable donc c'est tout à
fait normal qu'on regarde ce que font
nos partenaire pour avoir un benchmark
et pour s'en inspirer mais là encore en
termes d'efficacité parce que c'est ça
l'idée de que les gens retournent en
termes d'emploi c'est pas forcément
pertinent de plaquer ou d'appliquer les
mêmes règles Clément Carboni et un autre
élément c'est le le regret chez cet
ancien ministre du Travail de l'absence
de dialogue social c'est vrai que c'est
très fort elle va passer par par décret
c'est la loi marché du travail qui
d'être voté au Parlement qui donne la
main au gouvernement alors c'est quoi
c'est un constat d'échec des partenaires
sociaux c'est ça a été une feuille de
route qui était impossible à tenir pour
les partenaires sociaux et qui permet au
gouvernement de reprendre la main c'est
quoi l'explication oui je pense que
c'est il y avait une volonté de reprise
en main et donc cette volonté de
représenter dès le début dès 2017 alors
il y avait des choses qui avaient été
faites déjà avant mais 2017 c'était
clair il y avait le fait de dire déjà ça
va plus être financé par des cotisations
sociales ça va être un impôts donc ça a
pu être des justement des choses qui
sont à liées au travail ça va être un
impôt national donc là déjà on voit que
dans le financement il y avait une
reprise et puis derrière effectivement
rapidement il y a toujours le côté alors
c'est les choses qui avaient été ajouté
si vous n'êtes pas capable de vous
mettre d'accord c'est c'est
effectivement le gouvernement qui va
décider mais dans l'annonce au départ
c'est si on dit à peu près ce qu'on va
faire et si ce qu'on dit qu'on va faire
c'est presque mieux que ce que pouvait
espérer les employeurs je vois mal
comment la négociation peut peu aboutir
les des employeurs aucune raison
d'accepter quelque chose de moins
favorable pour eux que ce qui va se
passer de toute façon et que fera le
gouvernement donc c'est c'est oui il y a
un échec mais c'est un échec qui fait
partie d'une volonté de reprise en main
claire si je peux deux points sur sur le
reportage assez intéressant sur le fait
que le taux la 57 % du salaire
journalier est plutôt plus faible ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est qu'en plus
l'année dernière il y a eu une autre
réforme du chômage qui elle a touché non
pas le taux mais la manière de calculer
ce salaire et ce qui a été fait c'est de
baisser drastiquement la manière de
calculer salaire pour les gens qui
enchaînent des petits boulots et là on
est en train de faire quoi on est en
train d'essayer d'inciter les gens qui
sont chômeurs de longue durée à accepter
forcément des petits boulots ce qui va
faire qu'ils auront des filles après
leur retour de petits boulots ils auront
des allocations encore plus faibles
puisque avec ce nouveau modèle de calcul
l'année dernière ce sera plus faible et
ensuite enfin sur l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne a effectivement fait sa
réforme qui avec la descente à 12 mois
etc alors dans le cadre un peu comme la
France il y avait eu aussi la
décentralisation des négociations toute
une un pan de réforme entre dans les
années dans les années 2000
immédiatement ce qui avait suivi c'était
une baisse des salaires et une baisse
des salaires très très forte
c'est-à-dire que les bas salaire ont
vraiment chuté drastiquement mais même
le salaire médian a diminué en terme à
diminuer en terme réel c'est-à-dire que
le pouvoir d'achat du salaire médian a
diminué en Allemagne après ces réformes
là c'est quand même ça qui s'est passé
alors je voudrais ignorer 5 minutes
terminer sur la question on l'a déjà
évoqué mais pas d'une façon un peu
peut-être pointiste le chômage des
seigneurs des plus de 55 ans marque Coty
c'est moi quand j'ai vu cette réforme je
dis c'est vraiment le point le plus le
plus problématique de de du système
aujourd'hui c'est 36 mois donc ce serait
- 9 mois or on sait bien qu'il y a
énormément de seniors qui n'arrivent pas
enfin le le licenciement à 54 55 ans
c'est une catastrophe la probabilité de
retrouver un emploi les ultra faible
mais c'est ça le problème c'est que
beaucoup on va créer des des gens qui
vont arriver au minimum
on donne le calcul on dit voilà on va
vous donner effectivement donc trois ans
de chômage entre guillemets et puis
après vous aurez vous arrivez à votre
pré retraite et ainsi de suite et là
donc vous prenez votre traitement donc
c'est ça c'est la drame effectivement
c'est les plus de 55 ans qui sont de
moins en moins employables là aussi
parce que encore une fois on fait des
formations mais c'est pas forcément des
formations qui sont souhaitées moi je
trouve que ce qui est encore dommage
c'est qu'à 55 ans on est jeune parce que
on est d'accord que je les ai pas encore
mais moi je les ai donc de justesse
mais le gros problème c'est aussi la
règle du jeu c'est-à-dire la règle du
jeu qu'on donne effectivement
aujourd'hui aux français quand on
commence voilà les études on dit vous
inquiétez pas en France mais on est on
est protégé quoi qu'il arrive et on se
rend compte avec le temps que c'est pas
forcément le cas donc c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui il y a cette difficulté et
juste on parle tout à l'heure
d'injustice moi ce qui m'a choqué aussi
parce qu'on en a pas parlé c'est que on
a on réforme pas les intermittents du
spectacle ils sont pas concernés par
cette réforme ça c'est incroyable alors
qu'on sait que c'est là où il y a le
déficit à peu près 1 milliard d'euros je
crois par an
de l'assurance chômage justement et là
on les touche pas donc voyez si on veut
donner l'image de la justice ça commence
mal donc et donc là aujourd'hui ceux qui
vont payer le plus malheureusement je
pense effectivement les seniors et
encore une fois parce que on a un
problème de formation et de valorisation
du travail parce que les finances
justement ont beaucoup à apporter aux
jeunes générations et dès qu'on a 55 ans
ça a été complètement has been tu es
plus dans le milieu etc voilà on a
besoin aujourd'hui d'apporter cette
expérience qui permet justement
d'améliorer la qualité du travail
Anne-Sophie est-ce que pour vous c'est
le point le plus je sais pas quel était
employé injuste ou absurde de cette de
cette réforme oui complètement parce que
c'est vrai que comme vous dites beaucoup
des plus de 55 ans sont mis au chômage
mais c'est vraiment pas un choix et eux
pour le coup cherche cher donc c'est
vraiment pas un problème de volonté
comme comme on les vend les entreprises
dans lesquelles ils étaient ont arrêté
de leur proposer des formations depuis
longtemps exactement
les secteurs de formation donc et puis
surtout on va une égalité selon le type
et le statut par exemple en termes
d'employabilité en termes d'espérance de
vie on voit que les avocats les
professeurs de médecine les médecins
tout ce qui est profession libérales ont
en effet les personnes et bien son
maître on va dire d'exercer là peuvent
continuer peuvent monter qualification
et même continuent au-delà des limites
de retraite par contre en effet quand
vous êtes un salarié lambda qui
dépendait de la qualification de vos
entreprises là c'est beaucoup plus dur
et souvent les formations arrivent assez
tard on va dire pour préparer la fin de
carrière et c'est un élément et un débat
très important quand on parle en effet
de l'augmentation de l'âge de départ à
la retraite quand on parle de
l'augmentation de l'espérance de vie où
on sait que le nombre d'années
travaillées va augmenter pour pouvoir
avoir un Center trap plutôt des
retraites soutenables donc c'est vrai
que c'est assez étonnant de d'avoir ces
très formes d'un côté qui stigmatise et
qui est assez idiot pour les plus de 55
ans et puis tout se débat sur décaler
l'âge de départ à la retraite avoir la
formation des seniors parce que c'est
vraiment un tout on voit dans les pays
où on a eu une augmentation de l'âge de
départ à la retraite on a vraiment eu
des plans de formation de fonds qui se
sont accompagner en effet pour les
seniors pour pouvoir vraiment garder
rester au travail même au-delà de 65 de
65 ans merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat de sens public marketis je vais
appeler le titre de votre livre donc
c'est le deuxième tome en quelque sorte
reset de bienvenue dans le chômage
d'après ça tombe bien on va y retrouver
vos idées donc publier chez bookedis
merci à tous encore une fois